[Music]
joining me today is a Johnstone family
professor in the Department of
Psychology at Harvard University as well
as a New York Times bestselling author
whose new book enlightenment now is for
sale right now Steven Pinker welcome to
the Rubin report thank you I am I am
thrilled to have you here I think I have
emailed or called or contacted or pigeon
messaged everyone related to you or that
knows you in any way to get you here and
Here I am and here you are worked it
goes to prove that a little positivity I
think can make some things happen so
true yeah all right a lot I want to talk
to you about I thought before we dive
into the book and and all the the things
that you teach and write about and all
that I just I like hearing a little bit
about people's history and where they
come from and growing up and all that
you are Canadian and I've had a lot of
Canadians on lately I find there's
something about Canadians in general
that I like what is it about Canadians
that leads to a certain Pleasant
disposition well we're so reasonable or
so yeah
alight yeah sometimes people say think
the model of Canada's peace order and
good government yes and it's a country
that is that has been diverse for for
quite some time
Quebec where I grew up has
english-speaking community in a
french-speaking community and we we
didn't begin with a revolution unlike
the United States and we negotiated our
way to independence we're part of the
British Empire in the British
Commonwealth and kind of have that
British reserve and politeness yeah so
that we have we have some things going
for us a couple of things going yeah at
least until at least all the Americans
end up moving up there if things keep
going this way well the way we might
build a wall yeah right you guys may end
up building the wall exactly tell me a
little bit about growing up your family
what kind of family you grew up in in
the english-speaking section of Montreal
in Monroe it was pretty segregated when
I grew up I grew up in a Jewish
english-speaking community which was
known for producing among others Leonard
Cohen who is a contemporary
my mother's mhm the author Mordecai
Richler who was a contemporary of my
father's William Shatner Burt Bacharach
Wow
the Saul Bellow spitters person his
childhood in Montreal so it's a small
community that has a number of people
that were proud of yeah what do you make
of that that so many I mean that's a
pretty diverse interesting group of
people right there and I'm sure there
are others yeah I it it may just be that
having many cultural influences both
Canada's really couldn't dominated by
the United States it really is the
800-pound gorilla next door yeah so is
the American influence the British
influence the French influence perhaps
is just being in a cosmopolitan diverse
community know that help with that and
of course the the Jewish influence
although it was not I didn't grow up in
none of the people that I mentioned grew
up in an ultra-orthodox community high
grew up in a in a reformed temple we
didn't take God all that seriously but
we did take Jewish identity seriously
yeah I don't remember a moment in which
I decided oh I'm an atheist I just was
not a big issue one day or another do
you find that to be sort of standard
thing with most secular Jews I think
that's sort of East the ones that I've
been talking to on this show that I
think are sort of out there more that
seems to be thing that there's an ethnic
identity or a cultural identity that's
separate from the belief part absolutely
and I think that's more true of Judaism
than it is of say Catholicism where the
belief really is stipulated in Judaism
this is a bit of a kind of Don't Ask
Don't Tell as long as you have a though
as long as we pay the laws and rituals
right if you keep the Sabbath if you
have you know mots on Passover then
you're a good Jew and what you believe
is just not as important what one rabbi
said to my wife rebecca goldstein
another secular Jew mm-hmm well-known a
secular humanist writer when she talked
about her novel 36 arguments for the
existence of God a work of fiction which
is kind of the great I said and she
spoke at a Jewish Community Center and I
was a little worried whether there'd be
some pushback from the rabbi who
introduced to him afterwards he went
over he said you know there's nothing in
Judaism that says you have to believe in
God you just can't believe in more than
one of
that's I mean that's pretty perfect do
you think there's a there's an inherent
problem they're sort of disconnecting
God from reason if it really is well
just for the longevity of it let's say
oh yeah yeah it's a good question I
think that may have been part of the
explanation for why I mean there's so
many secular Jewish intellectuals kind
of immersed in argument dispute ation
particularly about morals and ethics but
without a bit but it was all argument
disputation it wasn't a catechism that
you had to recite there wasn't a set of
beliefs that you I have to have so there
was a tradition of disputation that's
what the rabbi's were famous for right
at the pill pole thing here splitting
and and maybe that was a contributor as
well but I went to public schools I went
and in fact when you go to public
schools in Quebec when I in my childhood
meant you had two Protestant schools
because it was divided along religious
lines they were Protestant schools and
Catholics so interesting Protestant
meant on Catholic basically everyone
else yeah who do Muslims and the Jews
and Chinese and so on there's a bizarre
system yeah how's how he just hadn't lis
unconstitutional in this country oh my
god I got to I actually got a pretty
serious Protestant religious education I
sang hymns we said the Lord's Prayer
every day I learned about the life of
Jesus so they had the Jews and the
Muslims and everyone in the getting a
Protestants yeah
and at one point I remember I was you
know eight and nine and I actually
didn't even belong to a temple I said so
it's my mother
you know one of my friends said that
that Jews aren't supposed to believe in
Jesus should I not believe in Jesus
anymore after you sent me their Hebrew
school so fast made my head spin
hilarious and him my teachers because
they couldn't hire Catholic teachers
either and virtually everyone in Quebec
is a francophone community or Catholics
it's actually hired Algerian and
Tunisian and moroccan jews to teach
French to the Jewish and Protestant kids
of Montreal the parson Kizza Montreal
did not learn French from native
québécois we learned it from Egyptian
and Tunisian immigrants how bizarre it
was I'm pretty sure I know the subject
of your next book I mean it's
like there's just so much richness just
in that or at least there's a little
comedy in there so I think it sounds
like your family was kind of on the
intellectual side or at least that the
county was red house was full of books
and magazines my my father was had a law
degree but didn't practice when I was a
child he was a and had a little bit of
real estate did sales before starting a
law practice pretty late in life my
mother was like most mothers of the 50s
and 60s a homemaker but then found a
career when she was kind of getting
bored when I became a guidance counselor
and then a vice principal of a high
school and and my mother Roslyn Pinker
very intellectual an intense reader
knows everything intellectually very
engaged yeah and my sister Susan de is a
columnist for The Wall Street Journal
certain have been in a couple of books
one on sex differences one on
face-to-face contact my brother Rob so I
work for the Canadian government for
several decades as a policy analyst and
an administrator so how much of the
intellectual pursuits that you all have
do you think is is biological versus
just learned experience yeah this is one
of the themes that keeps coming up
around these conversations and and it is
was a topic of my book the blank slate
in the modern denial of human nature
yeah
the blank slate being the metaphor that
I argued became kendama Nate and
intellectual life largely for political
reasons yeah can you explain that a
little bit for the people that don't
know the book yeah so the the blank
slate the modern denial of human nature
just was released in 2016 with an
afterword was about the idea that that
there is no such thing as human nature
that we are blank slates written on by
our parents by by the culture by
education and that there's no innate
human traits or ways of learning and
thinking it's it's you can program a
human however you want and I argue that
it was popular in the 20th century for
political reasons one of them being that
it seems like the ultimate way to
achieve equality you know
overall zero then zero equals zero
equals zero so we all have to be equal
right I argue this is a mistake in the
book that equality is really a legal and
moral principle to treat everyone
equally it's not really the belief that
we're all clones home like slates and a
lot of the book tried to both lay out
the science of human nature but also to
explore the political and emotional and
moral baggage and coloring and to try to
clarify it and so the difference between
equality of treatment and equality of of
our biological endowment was a major
theme that also course enters into
discussion of sex differences hmm where
one of the reasons that certain
intellectual factions certain parts of
feminism want to deny that there are any
sex differences they think well that
will make it impossible to discriminate
because there's nothing to discriminate
we're all exactly this board exactly the
same right
and I do that's a big big mistake
there's first of all there is a lot of
evidence that men and women aren't
identical in all traits yeah I mean I'm
not a scientist but I think there is a
lot of everything I think anyone who's
had a son and a daughter has been in a
heterosexual relationship yeah anyone
who's listen to gossip about anyone
talking about anyone else yeah many
women aren't really not this is not
exactly the same but I think the myth
that they're the same was introduced for
political purposes namely that would
make discrimination irrational right
because there's no nothing to
discriminate on and I argue that that
you know that's just a error in logic I
strongly believe in gender equity that
no one should be prejudged because
they're a man or a woman
partly because of a scientific fact that
there's a huge overlap between the sexes
in any trait you want to look at so you
can predict an individual's traits just
knowing that they're a man or a woman
but they the policy we should be fair
doesn't require the false belief that
were the same that we are single what's
the best have you heard any argument for
that belief that you thought made any
sense or you just for which belief or
the idea that that this that these
genders are equal like when because you
must hear this from other academics
right I mean we know
that some of this stuff is being taught
at schools yeah well there are you know
there's no doubt that there are there's
a normal enormous overlap there's no
doubt and and some of the differences
between the sexes are are pretty small
and and subtle so in say mathematical
ability which was one of the most
controversial claims about sex
differences it it could it went to a
huge firestorm when Larry Summers the
president of Harvard mentioned that
differences between the sexes might
explain why the number of engineering
professors at Harvard at MIT what wasn't
50/50 down the line male/female yeah
this is very much like the the James
d'amour situation with with Google it is
exactly it's almost it's almost a replay
yeah and and it isn't easy in fact it
would be hard to say that men and women
are better at math in general it's you
have to even drill down to certain sub
components like mentally rotating
three-dimensional objects that men are
clearly better at but women are better
at word problems in arithmetic and math
so it's a so some of the pushback is
that in fact the science is often
complicated you can't make a sweeping
across the board generalization yeah and
then the other kind of pushback for
people who defend the blank slate is
well yeah that's true of you know 2002
when your book came out but society is
changing and you know more women are
consuming porn and more women are having
multiple sexual partners and maybe the
differences say in sexuality aren't due
to human nature but just due to our
culture at a particular moment that may
become obsolete and that seems
incredibly dangerous to me to view it
that way
well maybe although you know you could
in some ways it's actually highly
progressive and even correct because you
could have said you know 70 years ago
women you don't want to go into the
professions they they want to stay home
with the kids and and housework and
that's what makes them complete and
satisfied and happy and there'll be all
you know neurotic and anxious if they
start to become lawyers and doctors and
we know from the course of history that
you know that's not true that when as
soon as the doors open women did pour
through the doors
and so that would be an example where
too strong a claim of biological
differences would have been refuted by
the facts of history so it's not a slam
dunk I mean it is something that has to
be examined on a case-by-case basis are
you shocked at how difficult it is to
talk about all of this without getting
yourself yourself or any of the people
that talk about it into hot water yeah
because you want that you have to go
through here as I can see you're you're
quite well-versed at you're probably the
best at it it's a lot to make sure that
somebody can't pinpoint that one line
but then they're gonna just you know
drag you for exactly right well and the
reason that I wrote the blank slate was
it wasn't so much
I have chapter on gender but the point
wasn't just to review the literature on
gender differences it was also to say
okay so what how does it matter for our
public debates mm-hmm and I also
documented in the book how even when the
book first came out there was a history
of people being deep platformed and
shouted down and called you know all
kinds of nasty names for for the view
that were not blank slates and I said
well look this is based on on emotion
based on bad politics not based on the
facts so I kind of I don't know if I'm
honest leading myself but I laid out all
of these political controversies so I
wasn't blundering into it naive I was
actually that was actually the subject
of the book right sometimes though that
that can't fully defend you there i an't
and in fact both larry summers and jamie
d'amour yeah they almost could have
taken their speeches and indicated in
case of larry summers partly did from
the chapter on gender in the book so I
managed to escape some trouble that
people who then repeated the arguments
got into trouble for yeah so it's
interesting you sort of laid out a case
beforehand to defend yourself you did
like sort of a preemptive strike exactly
where someone both of those guys I know
James I know James personally needs been
in here whereas like he sort of stumbled
into this thing and then the the
reaction the way it sorted out it just
becomes this bigger beast that you end
up fighting when you were just really
trying to talk about science well the
science I I wasn't just talking about
the science because I was talking about
first the science then what are the
political and moral Indonesian
which I thought got confused feeding
back on people trying to shoehorn the
science into a politically correct
position because they were kind of lazy
when it came to the politics you know I
don't believe in I obviously I don't
believe in discrimination against anyone
and but the point being that having that
belief doesn't mean that you have to
insist that were blank slates right and
I made that argument for other
controversies around human nature like
do we have any violent impulses where
there's there there's a kind of
political argument for a different
reason maybe people think well if we're
innately violent then we're kind of
doomed to war and forever and if you try
to reduce war you're just some romantic
peace Nick and it's hopeless and war is
in human nature therefore since war is
bad
and if we're violent then we'll always
have war we can't be violent and I argue
that's that too is illogical
we do have violent impulses I think
that's pretty clear but it's not all we
have we also have have the Faculty of
self-control we also have empathy we
have cognitive processes of
problem-solving so we can figure out how
that we can reduce war we've got moral
norms they're just certain things you
don't do and the fact that part of us is
violent doesn't mean we're doomed to
violence because part of us pushes back
on the violence I cited a statistic
that's that three-quarters of men and
60% of women at least once have had a
homicidal fantasy it imagined killing
something they don't like three-quarters
of men and 60% of ask yeah and and when
I introduced this fact in lecture and I
say well what does this tell us about
human nature tells us that
three-quarters of men are liars but but
I point at this this doesn't mean that
trying to increase peace is futile
because there are other parts of human
nature we can work with and of course
that was what led to my more recent book
the better angels of our nature and they
said not only is it possible it's
happened yeah but again that it's kind
of the the nexus between the political
on the one hand and the scientific on
the other that I was exploring and I
talked about how the people
who thought they were advocates of peace
tried to squash all evidence that people
have violent impulses because it was
just politically too uncomfortable and I
said that's first of all distorting the
science is never a good idea and is if
they clear about the politics then the
science doesn't even mean that we've got
to accept war yeah so for someone that
sort of insulated themselves from some
of this because you were doing the work
beforehand which is actually pretty
brilliant tactic are you afraid that the
hard sciences are going to be hit by all
of this identity politics stuff in a
bigger way than we're seeing right now
when it comes to to gender or race or
any of these issues it's not even so
much the hard sciences but the social
sciences well we know the social
sciences yeah haven't happened yet yeah
but you don't fear that it's gonna come
for the hard sciences too well there
there may be some aspects of genetics
and brain science that are that if
they're feeling the political pressure
the neuroscience of sex differences for
example did certainly the genetics of
intelligence and personality have felt
that political pressure yeah one of my
collaborators and former students said
James Lee presented a paper where he's
part of a consortium that for the first
time identified a number of genes that
were linked to intelligence
there's no IQ gene but there are
hundreds many probably no thousands of
genes that that could bump your IQ up by
a fraction of a point up or down mm-hmm
and they mean some of the first really
hard replicable discoveries because
there are a lot of bogus discoveries in
the past but there's was really solid
and there was there was pretty big
pushback including from the president of
the Society saying this is this is
fascist - this is unacceptable so there
was some pushback and this was this was
genetics yeah so what do you make of the
people that focus on like race and IQ I
you know I've had stefan molyneux here i
don't know if you know who he is but he
really focuses on that and I wanted what
I wanted to know from him really was not
necessarily why it really not what do
you think of this but why the focus on
that yeah that that team to me that's
the part I'm more concerned about yeah
I think it's a I think it's an excellent
question and it's one that that torments
me I mean on the one hand you could make
the argument well we should not be
afraid of the truth and for that matter
a vigorous exploration of the genetics
of racial differences might show that
there are no genetic differences
relevant to personality or intelligence
and that would give races of a really
decisive blow yeah but you never know
that before you look right so you can't
count on that you've course if you do
science you've got to be prepared for
any possibility there is I think a
legitimate question of whether we really
should be getting to the bottom of this
it's an argument actually goes back to
my old MIT colleague Noam Chomsky way
back in the 1970s said we can't insist
that the truth be one way or another
because that's just contrary to a whole
spirit of science but we don't have to
ask every question a lot of questions
that are scientifically pretty minor
they could have socially damaging
consequences so let's put them really
low on the list and he suggested that
that race an IQ for example is should
not be of interest in a society that
treats people as individuals because
then it's just like a correlation
between any two traits and that that we
should just be a low priority and
something we should ignore now that's a
little bit I think it ignores the fact
that there are people who already are
dividing humans by race and by and
measuring the outcomes and attributing
it to poverty or racism and then you
kind of say well gee if as long as we're
raising the question at all should we
look at all the hypotheses it might even
be an argument for just downplaying race
in general instead of dividing us up by
race and obsessively measuring the
differences look at things like class
and income mm-hmm because that that's
really what what matters more and just
not make everything a racial issue in
the first place so that whether the
racial issue is from biology kind of
fades in importance yeah you mentioned
the Nexus of politics and science I
really like that phrase because I think
of so many of the conversations I'm
having here it seems to me that politics
and science are really just linked all
the time it explains why so many people
want to talk to you
why they want to talk to the Weinstein
brothers in Sam Harris and so many other
people are you a little concerned that
it's becoming so political yeah I mean I
mean part of the it is that it's that
what but what I'm doing and what some of
the other your other guests have been
doing is to try to deep alit acai some
of the scientific issues and it took me
what I tried to do in the blank slate or
you clarify what what the political
issues are yeah and what it's almost
impossible these days right it is
becoming a little bit well it's it the
landscape is really diverse and divided
I mean there are they vary the identity
politicians and the social justice
warriors and the political correctness
police who are making things as
political as possible I mean they've
been around for a long time when I was a
student in the 70s there were plenty of
people who are shouting things like
fascists don't have the right to speak
or chanting mobs that shut down and my
Harvard colleague EO Wilson when he
published sociobiology this isn't a new
thing mm-hmm and there are certainly
constituencies that are totally opened
to D politicizing the science and
considering the politics on its own
terms but again there is a fringe that
appears to be more radical than ever
yeah how do you decide how much weight
that fringe has that seems to be one of
the themes these days it seems to be
very hard to tell is this just this
small group that's screaming a lot or or
has it truly infected not only a ton of
you know the millennial generation and a
huge swath of young people but that also
it does seem to be creeping up or
creeping down depending on which way you
look at it a ton of academics at
universities and all sorts of all sorts
of other people that that actually have
power well I think the academics have
been distorted for quite some time and
this is a an idea that's been pushed by
Jonathan Hite tetlock Jose Duarte shot a
lot of stern they had a pretty widely
discussed article called that the title
some like viewpoint diversity will help
social science where they gave a number
of cases some of which I had discussed
in in the blank slate of how just the
questions that psychologists asked the
the items they put on their
questionnaires the way they frame issues
just clearly has a left-wing bias that
they argued that if there were also
people conservatives in more of them in
psych departments then they would have
pointed out hey your questionnaire is
flawed right and that the actual quality
the science would improved and to the
credit of my field of psychology their
paper was published there in a journal
where there were thirty commentaries so
30 people had a chance to go after them
or teams and it was it was there was
disagreement but it's very respectful
they weren't called any nasty names it
was a really good debate but the the
question that you asked about how is
this a are the the totally illiberal and
radical movements the ones that that
just shout down speakers sometimes
physically assault them is that the
whole millennial generation or is that
just an increasingly vocal fringe my
mind was changed just a couple of days
ago when I read an article in Fox about
a new study Sam Harrison sent it to me
saying that actually support for free
speech is increasing including I saw the
article I saw the article yeah okay so
that you know that I wasn't I was kind
of surprised I wasn't totally shocked
yes at least my experience at Harvard is
that the students are all the ones that
I've interacted with admittedly a biased
sample but they are perfectly supportive
of debate free speech openness so it's
interesting so I mentioned right before
we started that I spoke at Harvard
through the open oh yeah that's right
and it was a wonderful group and I and
it was clear that they were politically
diverse and and all the other diversity
that everyone likes but that I don't
care about that much but afterwards we
we went to a dinner and there were about
thirty or forty kids I was with Brett
Weinstein actually and I asked them like
what do you guys do you are you guys
okay saying what you think and do you
think it's gonna hurt your grades or
your friendship and virtually everyone
said yes so I'm still struggling with
this because I didn't they said they
said yes that it would worry would
either hurt them or they've lost friends
I mean mostly I sense most of them were
kind of libertarian ish kind of live and
let live fun but certainly not all of
them but but virtually everyone at the
table said that they either were afraid
to say certain things to friend
or certainly to professor's so that's
why when I read the articles like that
at Vox and I go to these campuses and I
hear this consistently it's just hard to
grade and I and that's exactly why I'm
posing the question Pam yeah it's just
hard to this way this article was was an
eye-opening and it went against the
narrative that the millennial generation
are a bunch of snowflakes they're a
bunch of you know of cultural
revolutionaries the Warriors it's just
that that it there certainly is that
faction but it may not characterize our
era all together
yeah have you thought at all about how
much social media is a piece of this
puzzle well I don't know and that's
nowadays everything is blamed on social
media like you know what the role of El
Nino in that was on MySpace Yeah right
yeah I don't know a lot of this I think
predated social media I think that cable
news networks had had a role Fox News in
particular because it was so politicized
in a way that no previous network really
had been and and there are studies
showing that when a town gets Fox News
and you could do the natural experiment
because some towns got it before others
just because the way cable companies
offer different packages for no
particular reason you could tell the
town's the god Fox News became more
polarized and became and shifted to the
right well I really did have a causal
effect that's one case where it's not
just correlational yeah so you you had a
strange moment about a month or two ago
about two months ago now where you you
said something to the effect you someone
asked you a question at a panel about
the all right and and in effect you said
but I want to put words mouth what did
you say this is that's I don't want to
butcher open campus initiative oh it was
it there okay there you go so I know
this is a good group of people you were
sitting with it was of the and the topic
of the event was did political correct
correctness help elect Trump
it was held almost on the anniversary of
the 16 election and I suggested that I
thought it did in part because the when
you have certain ideas that are just not
discussable
on campus and you've got a savvy
interconnected community as the original
alt-right were a lot of people associate
cult right with the torch carrying
skinheads but I had a mind was the term
as it originally applied to internet
discussion groups mmm-hmm and that the
the danger of restricting debate on a
campus of making certain ideas taboo is
that when smart people do stumble upon
them then they number one are completely
alienated from the mainstream
intellectual life because they think
well this is a truth that they can't
handle what other truths can't and they
since the ideas never get expressed the
kind of pushback and and
contextualization and counter arguments
the kind of thing that you that you want
for any idea never happens and within
this like-minded community they
sometimes jump to the most extreme
conclusions so it's sort of a
self-fulfilling prophecy of sewers yeah
so an example being gender differences
if it's taboo even to mention the
possibility that men and women differ
then you stumble across some pretty good
scientific evidence that they do then
you might be like you know Milo your
novel is saying oh we should we should
have fewer women in medical school
because they're just gonna drop out and
have babies now I mean it's a totally
you know idiotic idea but the reason
that he could put forward an idiotic
idea is that since the whole existence
of sex differences never discuss uh I
never said that's an idiotic idea yeah
and likewise and there are a number of
other facts that are undiscussables
conclusions if you're not challenged
whereas if you bring them out into the
open then you you can put them into
perspective sunlight is the best
disinfectant in many cases it is another
example is that that rates of crime
differ between blacks and whites now if
that's a fact that's almost none
discussable but just go to fbi.gov look
up that they break down rates of crime
by age by race by state and you know
there it is now if you have never even
notice that then you can say oh gee I
wonder if you know african-americans are
innately more violent than well I
thought that's completely wrong because
we know that no two ethnic groups ever
have the same crime rate and they can
shift over time it used to be the Irish
that were they that had sky high rates
of violence compared to non Irish and we
know that that vanished over time and
the black/white difference might as well
but that second fact mainly ethnic and
racial differences are ubiquitous and
they can change the time will never even
get mentioned if the mere fact that
there is a difference is unmentionable
in the first place so that was my
argument yeah I gave some other examples
anyway that was then there's a doctored
film clip on some all right sites saying
OC Pinker's saying that the alt writers
you know is correct actually saying how
can we you know how can we start the off
right right how we're we're feeding them
inadvertently right you you were
basically I mean just for the layman
that's watching this I mean you were
basically saying allow for more
information so that those bad ideas
won't be able to flourish I mean that is
that sort of 101 version that was the
whole point exactly yeah it was it was a
edited to leave out that parts and then
the kind of regressive left picked up on
it to also suggest that I was
sympathetic to the alt right which is no
bizarre attribution you could imagine
and indeed enlightenment now has a whole
chapter on why the be all right is has
gone off the off the rails so
unfortunately this misconception after a
couple of after you know but a day was
corrected both in the New York Times and
in The Guardian I in England they came
to my defense and set things right but
it was a bizarre episode of how as The
Times put it social media makes you
stupid yeah precisely
alright so I do want to spend our whole
second okay talking about the book but
very quickly just when you dealt with
that whole thing I mean I remember
reading it and I think there was
something in an odd way I think the
reaction between as you said the
regressive left and the all right that
they were sort of teaming up on you
again yeah I guess
I thought that it was you know weird way
even though I know it probably
personally for you was no fun and you
probably had all sorts of people saying
terrible things to you and and all of
that that I thought if anyone has read
any of stephen's books or even remotely
knows what this guy is doing that i
think i don't know what you consider
yourself politically you strike me as
sort of just an old-school liberal i
don't want to counter that if he's
centrist moderate i have i have
sympathies to different policies and but
yeah i'm pretty eclectic and centrist
yeah so that that basically i thought
this guy is so obviously just decent and
coming at this from from a scientific
perspective that if this is what they're
gonna do we're at where you say one line
yeah this is going to just I mean really
my feeling was it could destroy like the
fabric of society really if we just
start picking off everybody and I've
seen a lot of instances of this and this
is you know when I've talked to when
I've talked to d'amour or I've talked to
Brett Weinstein or Lindsey Shepherd from
Laurier up in Canada and a few others
that they but I thought yours was just
such an example of this is so ridiculous
yes well so perhaps there was a nice
push back to it maybe and that was
exactly the New York Times response I
mean that's why they titled the op-ed by
that jesse single how social media makes
us stupid yeah
[Music]
you